now we can say about the girl who has
presented the cartoon and short subject
awards that she is that rare bird a
really good comedian but throughout the
business she's earned an even higher
tribute she's known as a good guy
completely unimpressed by protocol or
glamour I wouldn't be surprised if she
came out here tonight and levi's in a
plaid shirt miss Lucille Ball
you said you were gonna wear Levi's
nominee for the best cartoon our lambert
the sheepish lion Walt Disney
Productions RKO radio Walt Disney
producers rooty-toot-toot
United productions of America Columbia
Stephenville susto executive producer -
Mouseketeers metro-goldwyn-mayer Fred
Quimby producer the envelope please
the winner is Fred Quimby for two
Mouseketeers
mr. Quimby is going to accept this award
himself he's coming slowly after first
aid I wish you could see Lucille Ball
magnificent in a white gown and the red
dresses on top mr. Quimby is one
previous award for his cartoons and
we're rather anxious to hear what he has
to say Thank You Lucy
fellas nominated for best achievement
and one real short subjects are riding
the rails paramon jack ethan producer
the story of time a signal Films
production by Robert G Leffingwell
cornell film company british world of
kids warner brothers robert young son
producer the envelope please
the winner is robert young son for world
of kids
this award to mr. Robert Young seems
funny been accepted for him by Cedric
Francis who is associated with the Short
subject apartment of Warner Brothers
that's the microphone about two
receivers oscar and Willie speak on
behalf of mr. Young's in the very very
worn thank you
so far the speeches have been short and
to the point
those nominated for best achievement in
two real short subjects are Balzac
they film to Kompas AAF films
incorporated French produced by a film
to compose period
it allows stuff of that French danger
under the sea
danger under the sea Universal
International Tom need producer and
nature is half acre Walt Disney
Productions RKO radio Walt Disney
producer the envelope please
the winner is Walt Disney for nature Pat
Baker while we were waiting for this
award to be given that will be accepted
by mr. Paul J Smith who wrote the music
score for the film we couldn't go into
the number of awards that mr. Disney is
won the Fahlberg award three special
ones in 11 Oscars Walt Disney is Steph
and the birds and the bees savings and
with that short speech it makes 12
Oscars for Walt Disney Paul J Smith
accepted the award